and it's time for our superlatives
segment coming out of week three chris i
got a bunch of them today too go ahead
leave them off
no you oh do you have none oh no i got i
got a
point uh plenty here i'm ready to go you
want me to lead it off or you want to go
uh i'm gonna start i'm gonna start with
cam newton and i'm not sure that i can
say this but i'm going to go ahead and
say it this is the go
tuck rule yourself award for the new
england patriots to john gruden his
first time back
in new england since the tuck rule game
back in the 2000 playoffs it's amazing
that gruden hadn't been back there since
then
but he went to tampa yeah and tampa only
goes to new england like once a decade
right so yeah he hadn't been back well
he came back
and there was so much talk about hey the
raiders are 2-0 and they beat the saints
and you better believe in the raiders
and how dare you not respect the raiders
and
you should pick the raiders and derek
carr is going to have a big day and
you're going to be
sorry come monday when the raiders beat
the
oh 36 to 20 the patriots won and it was
that methodical
grind it out grind it out make you think
for a while that's what the patriots do
yes they make you think
for a while that you're that you're
actually gonna have a chance to win and
then you look at the scoreboard in the
second half
and you're getting lapped by the
patriots it happens all the time
always they just they smother you they
they make you think
you got a chance and then at the end of
the day you got no chance no
and they're the kings of like oh yeah
you're hanging around
oh okay you got a field goal we got a
touchdown
you got another field goal we got
another touchdown and you go man the
game's kind of even we're moving the
ball up and down the field except
they're scoring touchdowns and we're
kicking field goals and what the hell's
going on here
you're right it's impressive i mean one
of my superlatives i was going to use
them too
because i mean you talk about running
game by committee or who's got the ball
award
i mean holy cow over 250 yards rushing
by this patriots offense
michelle burkhead taylor you know the
rookie out of arizona he had a few nice
runs cam newton running the ball a few
other guys you're like who the hell is
this guy running the ball i've never
heard of you
i mean really it's quite impressive the
array of runs
and how they can attack you that way and
we've seen through three games them
really play three different types of
games on the offensive side of the ball
and be successful and cam newton he
threw that dumb pick
early on in the game where i just don't
think he saw the defender out in the
right flat but other than that
he was smart with the football and made
a few plays and that's all he needed to
do there so
good win fi by the patriots and uh
i don't know the raiders were one of
those teams that was 2-0 that i didn't
really know if they were a true 2-0 type
team quite yet
but this was the kind of game that's a
testament to the patriot way definitely
situational football making big plays in
big moments bend but don't break
unselfish play where you don't have
that one guy on offense that feels
compelled to have the ball in his hands
and creates a problem when he doesn't
hey this game rex burkhead's getting
three touchdowns he's getting three
touchdowns
next game it's going to be sony michelle
or someone else
that's just the way it goes when your
number's called you go out and do your
damnedest with it
and you wait for the next opportunity
and otherwise continue to do your job
and keep grinding and understand
that on those key moments on those key
plays there's another level of
effort and awareness that you have to
find that's what separates the patriots
from everyone else
you're right it is it's the attention to
detail on all those like
big moments that they've gone over they
never mess it up they execute the play
no matter what defense you try to throw
at them and they're impressive that way
mike and then
you flip it over to the defense it's the
same thing right darren waller darren
waller darren waller is the best tight
end of football after last monday night
we don't even hear his name yesterday i
mean you don't hear it until late
that just i think you know echoes what
you're saying about new england
you know oh yeah there's a new hot fad
in football look at john grew to derek
carr throwing the tight end what oh you
played the patriots and you've been
erased
i mean it's really that simple they're
just the kings of really doing
things that you you think are very
logical but yet they seem to logically
do them all the time and nobody else
does i don't get it
but uh that that all week long too right
they hyped darren wallace
devin mccourty hyping their water bill
belichick went on and on they were
comparing them to calvin johnson and
brandon marshall
and and i was stunned to see jc jackson
come out and say we got something for
him
right we and they did they did and what
they had for him was nothing
nothing you'll get nothing and like it
no and that's where
they're they're dangerous that way they
have so many safeties and cover corners
that are all different sizes and shapes
to match up with these type of football
players and i know joe jawan williams is
one of those guys yesterday
that did a really good job on him but
yeah the patriots just those guys
practice against gronk
i know that was good that's right
they've seen it all you're exactly right
and uh they're with it you're right
practicing against the team that knows
how to use the tight end too even though
it hasn't really come to fruition
in the cam newton era um but all right
you ready to move on to another game
am i good to go go ahead too much on one
man award
all right and that i'm going that like
desean watson just to talk about the
texan steelers game
i mean i'm just he needs help i don't
know any other way to say it and i'm
like deandre hopkins yeah
yeah i mean obviously so changing your
mind well yeah so far i'm wrong about
that one i i
am definitely i mean tony dungy i told
him yesterday i'm throwing in the white
towel i give up
it's over he won that argument you know
i really thought in a lot of ways it
might be a blessing in disguise and all
those things for desean watson and the
offense to be by committee and all that
but what you're seeing is you know i
don't know if the offense is good
good enough to have the whole committee
get involved
and then they can't run the ball and
then you see pass protection issues
again
i mean the first half of the game
yesterday the texans were leading right
i believe it was yeah 2117
and it was all watson buying times
buying time exploiting the zone coverage
manipulating it
bam completion that's all i saw in the
second half
it you know obviously the steelers made
some adjustments in the secondary and
continued to pressure him and he
couldn't find those people
but it's always on watson and i think
that's bothers me i know pittsburgh is
good
i get that but it's three games in a row
where it's just i look at texans and go
if desean watson doesn't make
unbelievable plays
they can't win a football game yeah i
agree with you and you know
this is one of the dangers of being the
coach in the gm because
we're all human we have emotions that
get involved
and i've heard some stuff that suggests
maybe bill o'brien and deandre hopkins
didn't see eye to eye that's why you
need to have a third voice
that can maybe mend fences they can
maybe say to the coach
i understand right it makes your job a
little bit harder
but but maybe we're better off with this
guy
than we are without this guy all right
uh and and look hey good for the
steelers
they're down 14 to three and they just
keep grinding they keep doing their
thing they come back to win the game
they're they're three and oh and they
haven't been
overwhelming so they haven't played
their best football yet that's what i've
got three wins in the bank much like the
chicago
bears do all right the next one for me
the donovan mcnabb award
yeah i'm saying it 12 years after mcnabb
learned
amazing bengals played to a tie that
there is such thing as a tie in football
he didn't know that there could actually
be
a tie to end a regular season game and i
really do feel like that was the
beginning of the end for donovan mcnabb
in a weird sort of way
that just like that seemed like that's
just a stunning admission
right for someone who's a professional
football player especially at
quarterback
because we saw a lack of urgency
from him in that game i don't want to go
back 12 years but it was like yeah now
we know why there's a lack of urgency he
thought they were going to keep playing
after the clock struck
zero in overtime so they get together
again eagles and the bengals
and they play to a 23 23 tied it's a
shame too
because i wanted a win for joe burrow so
badly not just because i picked the
bengals to win
but he was distraught after losing to
the browns i don't like losing i've lost
two in a row for the first time in my
life well
this isn't a loss but it's not a win but
it's the eagles and the bengals who play
once every four years
tying for the second time in 12 years
chris yeah it's um
wow that was a not fun game to watch
it was fun but it was also like man are
we
watching good football are we just
watching two really average teams just
not want to win a football game i don't
know any other way to really say it
the philadelphia eagles are very
underwhelming at this point
you know joe burrow yes likes a lot of
the things he does
he's fun to watch he can dissect you
make all the right throws
holy cow is he getting hit too much i
think that's what worries me more than
anything there
and then the philadelphia eagles it's
going to be the same old story i mean
it's oh it's all going to be
carson wins carson wins carson wins you
know especially on the day where nick
foles brings his team back from 16
points everybody's going to go oh they
should have never let go of
nick foles he should have been the
starter but i just again i'll i'll
defend carson wentz to a degree
he needs to learn how to manage football
games he has a real issue there
and not realizing the total picture of
what's going on in the game
and going wait this team can't move the
ball on our defense or whatever
i'm just going to play conservative here
for a little while but there's nothing
special about the eagles on offense
nothing what is scary about the eagles
there's
absolutely nothing no run game average
pass protection
i don't look at it and go oh wow
unbelievable creative plays down the
field
and then of course i don't look at it
and go oh wow what talent on the field
either
so i don't know what's expected there
but either way the eagles
look ugly and just every game is a
struggle for them
your dad made a great point yesterday
about carson wentz and i'm trying to
find it here because i want to get it
right and here it is scrolling scrolling
carson wentz where is it carson wentz
carson wentz carson wentz
basically that and he's got more tweets
than i thought he would have he he
treats
every play like it's the last play here
it is carson wentz plays every play like
it's the last play of the game
part of being quarterback is you have to
manage the game and he's right
yeah and it's almost like carson wentz
thinks every throw
potentially is going to result in 20
points
i i just just go through your your
i know plays one at a time go through
your reads one at a time don't try to do
too much
and if you focus on it methodically like
the patriots do very methodically
you're gonna look up at the scoreboard
at some point you're gonna say wow we're
kicking the crap out of it that's right
exactly it might not be pretty people
forget that it's ugly in the first
quarter if you're up by 10 points in the
fourth quarter
they forget nobody cares look they they
found
the guy found a way to win again played
it the right way and everybody praises
you
but yes this conversation my father and
i have had you've heard this we've
talked
we just talked about the guy that was
used to be like this deshaun watson it's
very similar
you know i feel like he's reigned it in
a little bit we saw a little yesterday
with the bad interception
but the same thing yes i mean we've seen
in all three weeks
of eagles play where they have moments
of the game
they're dominating in washington and
washington's showing
no signs of being able to move the ball
he throws two bad interceptions there to
jumpstart them
last week they climbed back in the
football game against the rams and it's
24-19
and they're in the red zone and he
throws a ball across his body across the
field late
interception you know that was huge and
then of course yesterday
you know there's the the the mistakes
jump starting the bangos and joe burrow
and a young team that doesn't really
believe in themselves
he gave them belief you know part of a
quarterback is and john gruden used to
teach me this like
you're sitting there on the sidelines
watch the game pay attention
you're sitting there going man that
other team can't move the ball
you know yes you don't want to like not
throw to open receivers but
on those plays where you drop back and
go oh that's a little dicey you know
what they can't move the ball i'm just
gonna check it down right now that's all
right i know we're up only six nothing
or whatever
but they can't do anything i'm not going
to try to squeeze it in there that's
part of being a quarterback in the nfl
one other thing from that bengals game
yeah i guess we could have given out the
rock'em sock'em robot award for joe
burrow the hit he took
leaked jackson the way his head jerked
and then he hit the ground
and he only missed one play you know we
haven't had this conversation a while
we've been so focused on covet and other
things
but boy there are circumstances where
you got to put that guy in the blue tent
you better make sure he's okay and i
don't know how he got back in the game
after only one play the way
that his head snapped when he got hit by
malik jackson yeah i mean
that was brutal brutal he's getting
killed through two
three weeks in the nfl and that really
does bother me i mean again this is the
the
the conversation we're always going to
have mike because you know guys like
that
i know joe burrow he's probably went
over there and said his shoulder hurt
after he fell
oh it was my shoulder i'm fine even
though he's singing i'm fine you're
probably seeing like
27 eagles defensive players on the field
they're not you're not gonna get it i
don't and i don't blame them you
wouldn't get it from me either
i'd make up an excuse every time i'm not
coming out of the game it's not
happening but
you're right that was a brutal hit and i
hope they can find a way to
protect him a little bit more
all right all right you got any more
yeah i'm ready for more ready i don't
know how i want to phrase this
you know oh i'm just not sure i really
that's never with you that's never a
good way
to start into anything but go ahead just
i'm not gonna we're on peacock
well we are okay don't don't no don't
i'm kidding
don't don't whatever you're thinking
about doing
don't all right go with your lead horse
award
go with your lead horse nick chubb okay
because nick chubb
is very exciting lately and maybe you
could figure out what kind of award i
wanted to give for the exciting
nick chubb okay stop oh i love peacock
i'm so happy to be on here
but nick chubb and what i say is go with
your lead horses i mean don't be
infatuated with the bright lights of
baker mayfield and odell
and jarvis landry and we can throw the
ball and we got these weapons because
the best thing the browns do is run the
football
and the best player on the offense is
nick chubb
he is a stud i mean without question one
of the
best backs in the game and we saw it
again yesterday when cleveland plays
through their run game
they really can be special that way
he's a special runner i still got you on
the superlative huh am i making you grin
still a little bit with the chubby just
stop
and just stop but stop go ahead see you
saw some of those runs i know we all
kind of sat there at all watching it
yesterday i mean the way
he can break tackles cut back and his
size the power he has and everything
like that
uh it's really special i don't know how
you feel about him mike but i feel like
clearly nick chubb is like
mccaffrey derek henry nick chubb would
be like my third running back off the
board i think he's that damn good
well and we got the concession last week
from oto beckham jr that he knows he's
not going to have a huge statistical
season with the cleveland browns
because what works is to run the
football and kevin stefanski responded i
said no no no
no no you know every week is going to be
different i still think they may trade
him i still do
i still do we got six weeks five weeks i
hear the trade deadline five weeks from
tomorrow i still think he could be
traded
especially if they're going to hitch
their wagon to nick chubb and kareem
hunt
you don't and although you need to have
odell beckham jr have a threat down the
field not when you can run the ball like
that
you don't need somebody stretching the
field when you're bashing the other team
in the face
at the point of attack and nick chubb is
popping through and running go ahead
bring it bring a safety up to the line
of scrimmage so what plenty of great
running backs have still been great
when defenses do everything they can to
try to slow them down all right next one
for me
this is uh this is uh well i you know if
you have to say it's a seinfeld
reference then you're trying too hard
but i'm gonna say
this is the how about six six is good
you got a problem with six award if you
remember that one if you don't like
there's nothing i can do to help you
uh steven goskowski six field goals man
less than two weeks
after he was abysmal on monday night in
denver to open the season
and mike vrabel coach of titans i talked
to him after the game never wavered
had plenty of confidence and steven
guzzkowski knew he was going to make his
kicks he's made a lot of kicks in his
career
and back 350 yarders and a 55-yarder
right down the middle to win the game it
was never a doubt it wasn't even a hold
your breath
and hope it makes it inside the sticks
he nailed it like an extra point
unbelievable and and that's what happens
when
you have a bad day
when your boss
supports you that's what gets you back
to the level that you're accustomed to
instead of spiraling
out of control and it helped the titans
win and he's kicked the game-winning
field goal in all three it's amazing of
their victories right and they're
somehow 3-0 and frable was salty about
that because they should be
you know they should be winning the
games a little more convincingly and he
said
if we don't improve by winning
we're going to learn by losing and uh
you know he's he's going to be on them
to get better against the run they gave
up too many expensive plays
but at the end of the day they still
they still ended up winning the game and
they're 3-0
and uh they're on their way yeah i mean
just uh we can't forget about them
no ravens chiefs bills yeah patriots
right you got to throw the titans in
that mix too
agreed agreed and the steelers are
crying out loud the afc
playoff field this year good lord yeah
that's right i'd probably put the
steelers
in the bills in front of the titans
right now it kind of kind of kind of
things like you just mentioned
you know you're titans of the team you
don't want to play you're right that's i
think i'm not you're better than them
but you don't want to play them you're
right they're going to be a pain in the
butt
because they just got a few freaks on
the field and they can make plays out of
nowhere
and they're they're great for playoff
football because there's kind of like
hey
their defense will do different types of
things and then offense you're always
like oh they just run and play action
run and play action we'll figure it out
and then of course they throw some
curveballs at you because they go yeah
we've self-scattered ourselves for the
playoffs now and
we do do run and play action a lot and
here's some curveballs and now you're
screwed over
and all of a sudden you're losing to us
but they're just a little concerning
that way like with like you said the big
plays
the in the past game i mean justin
jefferson went off
of course the run game runs early on
with dalvin cook
he was going off some of the stupid
mistakes i mean
the titans had chances to take care take
the game back a little bit
pick six giadevion clowney with a stupid
block back that gets called back they
end up getting
you know i think i think minnesota ended
up going down and getting a field goal
that drive or something like that but
um yeah it's just all over remember
remember we saw vrable talking to
clowney on the sideline
yes and now i i said i said what was up
with that he said i'm
making sure he knows the rules i thought
we'd gone over this our guys need to
know the rules it's that simple that's a
belichick
thing know the rules don't break the
rules don't give up don't kill
big plays and don't give up field
positions yeah that's uh they just
they've been sloppy that way they really
have and a lot of big plays their
defenses let up
offense you know spotty but tannehill
and derek henry make the big plays when
they have to i think that's the amazing
thing about that group there
um but yeah the titans 3-0 and yes your
vikings are
as we said last week d d
dead d-e-d yes i don't care
uh and you know it was the worst
possible outcome because one of our best
bets this week are both
uh best bets the titans giving two and a
half in minnesota yeah
so the worst possible outcome the
vikings lose but the titans don't cover
but that's okay
uh it's over it's done tank for trevor
i'm ready you're ready
well uh tank for trevor yeah well
you're right i mean i don't know maybe
maybe maybe it goes that way i don't
know where the minnesota vikings are
going to go but i can't see you guys
winning a whole lot of football games
this year
i mean what do i want to say here
um here we go again i don't know i don't
even know how i want to phrase this i
want to talk about the lions and their
defense at patricia
and just the big plays they made there i
mean i don't even know how to phrase it
i'm kind of just
spitballing here but uh let's see what
can i creatively come with
but just timely interceptions award
okay that's what i'm gonna go with just
because i want to talk about the game
i mean the lions did a good job
yesterday you know we hadn't seen
anybody
make kyler murray make mistakes the way
he did
yesterday and that's the one thing it's
one of the reasons i picked them in the
upset of this game
is because i figured they were going to
take away some of the short easy throws
and at least make him make throws down
the field into some tight windows
and they're not playing in their favor
but you're talking about like a
desperation win
wow i mean matt patricia stafford i mean
i think they're all on their last line
here they got to call like you know
regis filming and then
and call home like for help here it's
it's
it's an issue but yeah they saved
themselves yesterday with a big win on
the road
and it kind of makes up for last year's
blown week one loss or tie
that they had that they should have won
that football game but great job by the
lines and their defense
all right i got one more it is the where
is it where is it oh it's the after
further review award
because there was a point yesterday
where
the dallas cowboys
were down 15 points they scored a
touchdown
putting them down by nine points and you
know what they did chris
you know what they did remember what
they did last week yes they did it again
what no they didn't do it this time they
didn't okay
last week last week mike mccarthy
created the impression you're down by
nine
right in the second half of the game you
go for two because if you don't get it
you still know that you need two scores
to win the game so you're better off
going for two then
you get two you only need one score uh
or whatever no it was stupid it was just
the whole thing stupid stupid don't try
to
lie don't be logical about it it is
stupid but it's making me stupid but
here's the point
stupid mike mccarthy must have realized
how stupid it was because the same
situation
arose this week now it wasn't late in
the game but it was late in the third
quarter
and he went for one and made it an
eight-point game
keeping it a one-score game but knowing
that if he scored another touchdown he'd
need to convert the two-pointer to tie
instead of that crazy logic from last
year
i know i'm going to get the analytics
people up in arms again but
you look it's a very simple process you
put yourself in position where you're
one score behind where you can
if you fail your two scores down so
bottom line mike mccarthy must have seen
it a different way
he's not he's not being you know loyal
to the chart
at all times he went for one and kept
his team down by eight instead of going
for two so something changed
between last week and this yeah what
because i mean what
i mean logic logic changed i mean brains
i mean of course that
that makes no sense absolutely none
like you said you keep it to a one score
game
and then that other score you need okay
will be the two point conversion
from the two yard line that is better
percentage play than
wait if we don't get it now we're gonna
need to score a touchdown and then get
the ball
back on a separate position possession
and then go
get another score i don't know how any
number or formula can say that that's
not the right way to play the football
game
and like you said you always keep the
pressure on the team with the one score
game
now they have to manage the game a
little different because it's a one
score game where
if it's a two score game they can be
maybe a hair more aggressive or
something like that because they go hey
it's a two score game let's take a shot
here if it's a one score game
that's when you tend to see offensive
play callers go oh well i don't want to
make a mistake here let's try to run the
ball let's be conservative let's run the
ball
run the clock all those things so there
is no logic i don't care what the
einstein formula
is anything like that when you're down
by nine
you kick the extra point to go down by
eight and keep playing football
you got anything else no any other
awards yeah i mean you know i'm
surprised
you're not giving kyle shanahan i i
would call it the next man up and next
man up and next man up and next man up
and next man up and next man up and next
man up
next man up awards well i i have i wrote
the belichickian award and i really
thought this because of you because you
always say like kyle has a chance to be
the next bill belichick but i mean
that's where like the 49ers are getting
to
we don't even care and we expect them to
just run over teams now
and we do we just go well shanahan's a
good coach he'll get it done and he did
yesterday doesn't matter
doesn't matter who's playing running
back who's playing quarterback
got receivers from who knows who the
hell they are
but they move the ball make the plays
eight for 12 on third downs with a
backup quarterback
yes that's a testament to my friend kyle
shanahan who is an awesome coach
and even with the banged up football
team you could see him and john lynch
have built something there
that can sustain or at least last
through the injuries here to where
they're
they're going to buy themselves
sometimes to get healthy and and still
be in a great spot
i actually said that last night in the
digital uh
round table that did you do after
halftime and i said bella chicken
because this
is the next man up no excuses
who cares if we have injuries we expect
the replacement
to perform at the same level as the
person he's replacing even though he's
lower on the depth chart for a reason
we we're not going to get down in the
mouth we're not going to say woe is us
we're not going to say look at all these
great teams in our division this isn't
our year
we're just going to keep plugging away
and
now again it's the jets and the giants
but still they
are still in the nfl and they beat the
crap out of them in consecutive weeks
they had to go back and play on a on a
surface they had no desire to play on
and they still pounded the giants
into that into that new field turf at
metlife stadium chris yeah
i mean it it was and and again you know
yeah mullins was did well the defense
played very good
i think that's the thing that you can
really look at you know nick bosa there
was no let down there
but the big thing to me and again not
that i could sit there and like
break down the game yet but it just
shanahan
i mean the more i looked at the game
every time i looked over it was some
cool design run plays cool design pass
play
and the statistics kind of tell you that
i mean it's 38 running yards by mckinnon
it's 31 yards by brandon ayuk a receiver
so he's second
leading in rushing wilson's got 15 and
then the passing game there's like
nine 10 guys who saw the ball ayuk born
wilson dwelly all were 50 yards and
above
and then another bunch of guys who have
two or three receptions so that to me
when you start to see
stat lines like that that means like oh
wait we don't have stars
right now we're a little banged up i'm
just gonna have to find ways through my
creative coaching
to get everybody involved so the defense
doesn't know who the hell to defend or
where it's coming from
and that's what they did yesterday
shanahan's scheme and creativity just
wore the giants down
but the fact that the backups can come
in and run those plays
i know the necessary precision and
effectiveness is amazing and it's a
testament to how they practice
and it's a testament to the faith that
kyle shanahan has in his guys
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports